- What's the number one thing
you want everyone in this room
to walk away with?
- That I think there's literally
300 million different ways to
win in the US if that's how
many people we have. Right?
There is no blueprint,
there is no exact way.
It only comes down to being
able to factor in the 40 or 50
indexes, input points,
context points around your life.
And then
navigating through that.
What I really want is for people
to understand don't do it
like me, don't would like you,
don't do it like Zucks,
don't do it like Travis,
don't do like Cuban.
Spend as much time as you can,
Steph, I'll be honest
with you maybe you
know the answer, I'm actually
weirdly asking you if I knew how
to help people create
more self-awareness,
it's what I would sell.
I don't know if that becomes
through therapy or some system
I don't know, I really don't.
- [Stephanie] My fear is
actually the reverse in terms
of with all the information,
with all the self-help,
with all the people on and
Instagram saying
these three easy steps.
The fear is we are telling
people as soon as you have a job
if you have a job like, click,
and when you meet a man that you
like, click, and then you can
afford a house and you have a
baby all of these things
are the recipe for success.
Well, if you're using some
kind of Cosmo checklist for the
recipe for success you are going
to end up very unhappy because
success is internal.
- So I'll go different way.
Fine.
But I actually think were in a
much better place than we've
been in the past 60
years on this issue.
- Why?
- Prior to this world where we
had so many more opinions and
platforms, we had three channels
that told everybody that thing.
There was three old white guys
that owned ABC and NBC and CBS.
- [Stephanie] That's a
great point.
- That completely pushed down to
them what it was supposed to be.
Now at least we have
a lot more voices and
there's more things to navigate.
(light hip hop music)